Crazy, call me psycho,
call me whatever you want,
but I can't be the only one who does this.
I don't have any kids,
so my partner is not a dad.
But guess what?
Father's Day is coming up,
and I am for sure getting him a Daddy's Day gift,
so to speak. I have no shame.
My love language is gift giving.
I will take any opportunity I can to make someone feel special
and see a dad
or a father. A father.
But, I mean, he's my daddy.
So let's make it more socially acceptable to give your daddy.
I'm honestly
just making him a little basket of things that I know he needs. Socks,
boxers, a notebook, and a little card.
Because I just want to make him feel special.
May not be a father,
he sure as heck is my daddy.
Okay, so nothing crazy here.
Him, a notebook,
pairs of socks,
because he always goes through socks,
underwear, and these shoes. Basket.
I'm just gonna throw this in here and see how it looks.
There you have it.
Just a couple little things for Daddy Day.
Oh, my goodness.
You like it? I love it, baby. Awesome.
You look really good.
Thank you. You know,
I'm gonna try these on right away. Let's go.